now talking about accusations of racism
I want to bring to your attention the
ugly face of woke far left hate and
hyperbole Samantha false berated her own
father who had lost his battle with
cancer at his own funeral in front of
what color is her hair going to be why
because he was a cisgender white male
Trump supporter sounds about right oh my
God
because when you died it solidified the
fact that she'll never be what you could
have been but only what you are and what
you are is a racist misogynistic
xenophobic trump-loving sister straight
white man
it got worse than that
it's just some random lady who some
random bimbo sitting on her father's
grave okay why do you have to include
cisgendered white male what does that
have to do with anything if you're gonna
go after him when you go after his
qualities what you could have been would
you want him to be gay and black right
like we're supposed to accept people as
they are as they are by nature but we
can't be accepted as we are by Nature
we're bad for being cisgender and white
like it's just should have dyed his hair
we can go on and on about how stupid
this is but I I can say that I think the
fa I without knowing anything about
these people there's obviously some
massive dysfunction in this family that
this young woman feels at all
comfortable getting up in front of her
entire family in front and family
friends and his co-workers and whoever
else he was there and insulting her
father and saying that she's
disappointed in the human being that he
was if I even started to utter one word
like that at a family funeral be barred
from the family that wouldn't be barred
from the family I would catch a beating
from every one of my aunts they would be
like pocketbooks the grandmas the
grandmas the grandmother they know them
would be straightening everything out
fast no one would allow that to go on
because it's disrespectful even if
things are bad you just zip it pumpkin
this is gross oh you know how I feel
about funerals you go to your father's
funeral I don't care if you have to swim
there getting over that tape never he
didn't go to his father's funeral but
she'd gladly take his money and make the
world a better place yeah good luck with
that you know we're really allowing the
most putrid ugly souls to believe
they're morally Superior we've allowed
them to think that because I identify as
victims and push some Twisted notion of
race and gender theory that they are
progressive when they really are nothing
but bile-filled race obsessed miscreants
now the young woman I don't know
as non-binary and users they then
pronouns and describes herself as a
black supremacist the New York Post has
since revealed far from being some
tragic victim she is a Pampered princess
brought up in the lap of luxury you see
the father she trashed at his own
funeral what a nice looking guy Donald
Fox Billy founder and former CEO of
Credit Acceptance according to New York
Post Samantha attends a university in
Georgia where tuition fees are around 57
000 per annum that's you how is he
racist if you're black
doesn't that mean he had to do it with a
black chick if she's black I mean I I
don't know doesn't she look she looks a
little black she could be one of those
Rachel dolezal crazies who pretends to
be black I don't know but yes you make a
good point if she is indeed black but
you can't you can have black friends and
marry a black woman and still be racist
that's what they say Bliss and she lived
with her mum and dad in a 7.3 million
dollar mansion
Samantha does identify as a black okay
she's pretty girl and she's mixed race
and a surprise
not only dated black women but married
one and had children with her and her
father was it doesn't get more not
racist than that like you told him to
not be racist and he literally married a
black chick that's because action speak
louder than words but these people think
words speak louder than action so I
guess he had to vote for Biden to get
his daughter's approval I don't even
know well that's philanthrus who created
the Don Foss annual scholar ship program
and awarded more than 630 scholarships
to students well they weren't students
they weren't students of color so I
guess he is a little bit um you know
shame on this girl she should be shunned
by her family one of the things that
I've learned a lot about in the past
couple years is discipline get control
of your head control your mind and learn
discipline and so you stop talking
yourself out of things and so you know
Tom Shea the Navy SEAL who we work with
I went through his 21 day challenge
where he gave me some tasks to do every
day and part of the challenge was to
wake up every day commit to doing it and
every time I started to talk myself out
of it I would have an excuse run through
my head some lame ass excuse and there
are four main excuses that he teaches
people that are that ruin lives that's
why we're doing the 21 Day Challenge
again together which Sunny is not
excited about because he's going to have
Tom on his ass if you guys actually
would like to do that with us go to the
link in the description because there's
a discount code come and do it because
guaranteed in one area of your life
there's something you're not doing
because you talk yourself out of it
every day you can go to the top of the
description click the link and buy it
with code Sunny fast50 for a nice
discount and we'll be doing it with you
guys will be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool deserves to be
smashed and humiliated at his own
funeral and for the rest
is the one who posted that video to tick
tock not only did she choose to hurt her
family at the most vulnerable moment but
she wanted to earn social media cred for
it iron straw and a professor of
theology summed it up with these
comments about that viral video he said
this is a perfect parable of what
wokeness begets when it takes you
captive hatred unrelenting
self-righteousness no graciousness no
kindness moral superiority needless
Division and a rancid disposable of
people who do not share your views
perfectly put there how did a girl who
was raised in in the the top one percent
of society not pick up any manners along
the way what went on in that family that
this was allowed to go on that that she
was allowed to be that kind of a human
being hold up do you want to watch the
full video
[Music]
when you died I felt like there was a
whole I missed something but it wasn't
you
it was the idea of what you would become
I missed this chick's gonna be an
English teacher she's going to be an
English teacher this is the most basic
speech I've ever heard it's not what you
were there was a hole it was what you
could have become being able to Hope and
wish that one day you turn the corner
and see the world from my perspective I
missed the idea that one day it might
help me fight for the things that matter
I missed my fantasy of you
so there are a lot of people who have
inadequate fathers and it's like you
don't have that problem no we don't know
that we don't know what this man was
like as a father we know that he he
clearly provided material wealth to and
and you know the top one percent he he
sent her to the best schools uh he sent
her she lived in a mansion I'm sure she
was wearing nothing but designer Duds so
she she was provided for in that way
maybe he was not nice maybe he wasn't
warm maybe he never spent time with her
maybe he spent too much time on his
money we don't know but you don't have
the market cornered on human suffering
sweetheart a lot of people have shitty
fathers I'm sure anybody you're dead in
a third world country would trade places
with her in a heartbeat so I don't feel
bad yeah I think it's really I think
she's just a I'm so embarrassed for her
and I hope that she can grow and look
back on this one day and cringe and say
what kind of a person was I but to have
this that's like if you imagine you go
like unwoke and then you have to watch
yourself say that that's like Beyond
that's crazy can you imagine standing up
at Daddy's funeral and talking about the
one time he got he made you mad and
you're glad he's dead now because you
focused on that one that one aspect of
your relationship with him could you
imagine if Uncle Paulie was there or
Uncle Tommy they would knock your block
off and you would deserve it right I
mean think about it could you even
imagine seeing all those big giant fat
Italian hands coming at you you would
deserve it she deserves it the fact that
she'll never be what she could have been
but only what you are and what you are
is a racist misogynistic xenophobic what
is xenophobic again
are afraid of anybody that is different
from you you don't like anybody that is
from other countries please remember
that she disrespected and disregarded
the lies and death of the entire
communities
you told me to Never back down so I
won't you know for a fact that even
again so I'm not afraid to share my
peace
you are everything I Aspire not to be
and I refuse to stand up here and sing
the Praises of a man who was the
Paradigm of white supremacy so I'll take
your racist mindset I'll take your money
and I'll take your advice and I swear to
God I will make this world a better
place not at all because of you but an
exact opposition to you
he literally had like was giving kids
free college and [__] yeah what are you
gonna do eight thousand six hundred
something thousands of scholarships went
out whatever wow that's crazy I wonder
what she's gonna do that's gonna make
the world a better place with her
made-up problems all right thank you
guys so much for watching make sure to
like subscribe follow me on Instagram at
sunnyfaz
I do yeah do you all right and I'll see
you later
[Music]
good